herzlich kommt natürlich bedeute eine
unbewältigte zusammen mit
welches ist ein format falls jetzt noch
nicht kann der junge jeder kennt ja also
wir sagen ich bin ich okay alles klar
noch nicht ganz über die sebastian bevor
wir anfangen noch eine kurze erklärung
der kalk gehört luca hat vitello auf der
stirn stehen das ist eine plastikflasche
der er mal augen aufgeklebt hat vitello
ist meine wittlich in der mitte habe
andreas gabalier auf der stirn stehen
das ist ein österreichischer
schlagersänger und max ganz rechts hat
helmut der wrestler auf der stirn stehen
das ist eine figur aus einer gang
nichtaufnahme die wir 20 minuten vor der
aufnahme von diesem video hatten
max hat einfach so eine figur gespielt
die aussah wie ein höhlenmensch und hat
der helmut der wrestler genannt und ja
die hat er dann jetzt hier auch bekommen
natürlich bin ich weiß wie bastian wenn
man von jedem von uns ein foto ist ein
das bin ich gut das hätte das macht auch
vor mir noch mal einen level von vor
drei wasser jetzt ein foto von einem
hund eine den braunen koffer aber
wachsen körper also ich finde das ist
okay jetzt lebe ich in dieser unbekannte
welt gehört ich würde sagen nein nein
nein ich glaube ja sagen wird es sie nur
naja also jetzt mal angenommen so
features griffin ist auch lebendig aber
der ist halt nicht ihre denken testen -
du bist du vielleicht den werden
wahrscheinlich schon hart wenn ich ein
und die cartoon charaktere schwierig
es wird hat ihn eigentlich nein oder
also ich mir mal cartoon was das cartoon
cartoonist so diese cartoon zeigt doch
klar das gezeichnete ja dann schon dann
schaue ich schwarz ok also ich bin nicht
weil ich bin ich männlich bin ich am
leben der hand wie wenig einbrechen
das komplett mit stürmer also ich bin
männlich
wenn ich nicht weiß nicht antworteten
will also der bei den damen so und
wieder endet ja jemand vermisst
das könnte so aussehen dass hitze
anderes bin ich ein mensch
nein nein
die chance deines lebens habe ich jetzt
schon sagen wenn ich hab ja ja nein aber
ohnehin kein mensch das nicht mehr dicht
und ich weiß nicht der einzige
auf den es überall einfach geraten
max ist nicht hier nicht hier ist eine
serie vollgas gibt es nicht mehr
wer jetzt nicht ob ich bin wenn ich bin
noch am leben und ich bin nicht sturm
woche bin ich ein mensch und dann
bestimmt das verteidigen ob mit der
anderen menschen hier das ist ja das bin
ich ein fiktiver tag der wein oder ein
bier konsumiert heißt zu lagern oder bdi
[Musik]
hat angeblich schon fange erst mal gibt
es serien
zusätzlich gibt es eine serie von
unserem redakteur zusammenzufassen ich
bin kein mensch ich bin weder männlich
noch weiblich und ich bin nicht wurden
und es gibt serien und es gibt sie kenne
ich meine person ja ja ja wenn ich meine
person
aus der unterhaltungsbranche also ist
dieser serie oder dem film oder musik
oder so
mit dem ersten teil des parks
unterhaltungsbranche würde ich ja sagt
zweiter teil war okay wenn ich englisch
gemacht hat als erwerber der und herr
brender sei gibt es eine marke zu mir
noch nicht zu machen komplett das wasser
wird
ich bin kein fiktiver kehrt also also
billig wird es eine real existierende ja
ja
innerhalb beliebig deutschland lebt also
ich spreche kein englisch ich bin nicht
wenn ich bin nicht weil ich ich bin
nicht volley und ich liebe dich denken
endlich und in serie ich bin ich und ich
kenne mich ich habe keine ahnung ob ich
glaube ich auf so eine frage stellen und
dann nicht auf dem richtigen weg
hier bin ich
oder wenn ich nur eine person also wenig
glück bin ich die nur 4 3 kennen oder
kennen auch andere dass leute die person
bin ich also irgendwie sondern so einen
kleinen mein schlechtes also nicht
eindeutig zuzuordnen
ja bin ich die bedingung dass es viele
top eine schwierige frage weil egal wie
die antwort es wichtig nur verwirren
also ich würde ich würde eher sagen nein
das ist es nicht angehen
ja kann man so nicht da erklärt haben
ich hätte mir das spiel erstellen
einfach ein einziger hat persönliche und
der übersichtlichen mir sofort haben sie
dass sie genau richtig bis zum heutigen
tage auf die italienische grenze um die
winterspiele sperrschild kann man sich
in dem computerspiel gang gehen
vorstellen welcher optiken habe
angekommen aber ich würde aber ich will
den aktionären zu sein bin ich helmut
dietz war also da muss schon den ganzen
abend sorgen
hier sind bild von helmut und hier ist
ein bild von der katze das mit dabei
sind so weit weg ist unfassbar
da ist ein bild vom roten bei erst muss
ich mir einfach wichtig dass hier von
roth
warum ist diese banale geld und handy
der frau regina fall gar nichts mehr wie
vorher gewusst was bei der party hey
warum ich plötzlich auf dem boden ich
englisch ja ich wohne nicht in
deutschland will ich in deutschland
bekannt das bekam das ist kommt immer
darauf an so wie sag mal eine person so
vermögen von der nacht lang haben
wirklich international bekannt sie wäre
dann natürlich ja nicht was aber auch
mal deutschland gehört sind das 43
sondern also bin ich nicht außerhalb des
deutschsprachigen raums bekannt ja dann
ja für youtube gesehen
nein ich wende mich darauf komplize ein
okay gibt den tipp 4 3 dessen cassel 43
haben alle schon mit der person videos
gedreht
manche kollegen
nein nein ich bin ich franz müntefering
auch jetzt auch gemein als du hast gar
nicht die ganzen namen
jessica biel haben gerne gehört wird
jetzt müssen wir gewinnen ist mal wieder
das hat mir den namen überlegt das ist
der ganzen abend wollte seine
berufsbezeichnung merke ich finde ich
bin kein youtuber bin ich musiker ja ok
alles klar
obwohl lediglich wirklich verbringe ich
zeit und youtube ich will aber sie die
nein nein nein oder das ihren baum
einfügen
aber da kam hier bitte kassierten warum
entstehen
ich habe schon mal habe ich schon mal
öfter mit der person habe ich auch
meinen kanal ein die mit der person
aufgenommen
sie hat auch ein sehr scheues ja das ist
ein kanal einen kanal name ist ja ja ja
bin ich eine website nein bin ich
helmut der wrestler ja
[Applaus]
es ist fair
ich wünsche dir also helmut warf als
komplett falsch vor bin ich jünger als
40 40
mein pizza wenig öffentliche person
ich komme nicht aus einem videospiel
oder dort etwas besser mit den personen
entspringt seiner fantasie der fans das
auge klebt du hast die augen offen ist
im leben mache ich denn sonst machen und
misst also bin ich mit allen ja-wort
kraft gesagt und geschrieben
doch mit ich habe direkt auf der kippe
wieder dort
bands und sänger fängt man am ende mit
einem dreier aber lichtjahre arbeiter
besonders schon nicht das war 2007 das
in der beschreibung vor dem diktieren
für euch vorgeschlagen das video
widrigen geht am ein kanal ist schon
schnell ganz kurz ganz gut an den rennen
begleitet das noch gut bei sowieso eine
postkarte und ihr habt ihr keinen bock
drauf